hey guys it's angelica with max tech and
i hate
upgrading phones i have and i'm
currently using
an iphone 10r and i'm the only one in my
family that chose
not to upgrade to this current 12 line
for many years i owned an iphone 7
and refused to upgrade until max gifted
me this iphone 10r
that i use to this day i've never been
the type to want to upgrade
even if my phone is getting outdated
slowing down
and losing battery health that is until
this upcoming 13.
in this video i want to talk about some
of the rumors we've heard about this
upcoming iphone
and why they've convinced me to upgrade
this september
when apple releases it at their annual
event the first thing that
instantly caught my attention was the
rumor of
in-display touch id coming to the iphone
in october of 2020
love to dream tweeted out mesa utts for
iphone
which john prosser then translated to
under the screen touch id
since then multiple sources like
bloomberg and mingchi kuo
mention the same thing but also saying
that the 2021 iphones will be keeping
face id
and then in january joanna stern from
the wall street journal
said the exact same thing this is
something that i missed dearly from my
old iphone 7.
i loved touch id and that is one of the
biggest reasons why
i did not want to upgrade don't get me
wrong face id is great
but there's something about being able
to unlock your iphone without having to
hold it up
that i really liked i also have to have
two separate face id scans for myself
both with
and without glasses which really sucks
because you're only limited to two
and i'd really like to be able to set up
another person with my face id
on the other hand with touch id on the
older iphones
you could have up to five fingerprints
and of course for the past year
face id has been the opposite of
convenience because of masks
you either had to pull it down or
manually type in your password
every time you were out in public
although with the release of ios 14.5
you can finally unlock your phone with a
mask on
but you need to own an apple watch which
a lot of people
like me don't so that made
no difference and touch id would have
been perfect to have
but now with the iphone 13 we're
expecting to get the best of both worlds
literally because it could have that
touch id
but still keep face id as well so you
won't have to worry about having your
phone out or face
covered so that's something i'm really
excited for
and according to mark german the scanner
will be supplied by
qualcomm just like the samsung phones
and the fingerprint sensor in the newest
s21 ultra
is amazing being much improved from the
previous s20
because of its new size so it's
extremely reliable and fast
and i'm really excited about getting it
on the new iphone however
ming chi kuo recently made another
statement
saying that the 2022 iphones will get
touch id
meaning that there's a chance apple
won't make it happen with this year's
but of course nothing is confirmed so
fingers crossed the next thing that
everyone has been waiting forever for
is a smaller notch and we're finally
getting it
for over six months we've had many
conflicting leaks about the new notch
with some people claiming it will be
thinner with the receiver moved to the
top
and others claiming it will be less long
and more a hamburger style
it seems more likely now that it'll end
up being the latter
so we can expect the 13's notch to look
something like this
not only that but the face id system
will be redesigned and
improved and because of that
front-facing portraits would be better
as well
which is great we've had this same notch
design
for years and like i said i have a 10r
and i'm already so sick of it it's huge
and extremely outdated at this point
most phones on the market have a tiny
hole cut out on the display that's
barely noticeable
this huge notch is a pain and gets in
the way when you're watching videos
movies
and playing games it's about time that
something changes
so i'm really looking forward to owning
an iphone with a smaller notch
and that could also make the front
finally stand out from the rest of the
iphones
the next thing that's super exciting is
the addition
of an always on display samsung has
already been making phones with this
feature
but now we hear that the iphones will
have it too
according to max weinbach and everything
apple pro
it will display the time battery life
and
minimalistic notifications the always-on
display on the apple watch looks
great and it's a huge convenience
feature that many people
specifically upgraded for and along with
that we're finally getting
120 hertz after years of anticipation
a lot of people thought we were gonna
get it on the iphone 12s
so when we didn't it was a huge
disappointment
apparently that was because of battery
life concerns
apple had to choose between 120 hertz
refresh rate
or 5g for the iphone 12s and
they chose 5g because it's much more
marketable to the masses
but that issue will be solved this year
with a newer bigger battery
so now apple can include that 120 hertz
adaptive display
which will be supplied by samsung this
is something that's
already flagship it's something that all
phones should have
so apple is only now just catching up to
this point this is a big reason why
i want to upgrade the 120hz displays on
the samsung's are extremely nice and
smooth
making the hertz on iphones look
terrible
in comparison and with promotion
technology apple could possibly limit
the always on display to one hertz if
they wanted to
like on the apple watch so that would
save
a lot of battery but as expected this
feature will most likely
only be coming to the pro models which
will create a higher incentive for
people to spend more
last year out of the entire 12 lineup
the best-selling model was the regular
12. but
now that could possibly change another
big change said to come to the lineup
is vapor chamber cooling this is great
because the current models are being
limited
due to heat issues currently iphones do
not have a cooling system
they cool passively which means that the
heat gets transferred to the chassis
thus cooling itself down vadim has done
a multiple gaming comparisons with the
12 pro max
and it always ends up dimming
drastically
especially when playing games like
gentian impact that require a lot of
power
this can be very irritating because it
condemn itself to the point where it's
difficult to see and play
the previous samsung note 20 ultras were
shipped with both graphite
and vapor chamber cooling and apparently
they both worked
pretty well so if the iphones ship with
this cooling system
they should be able to perform much much
better something else we're hearing
is that censorship stabilization from
the 12 pro max model
should be coming to the entire 13 lineup
this is exciting because the tech
works great on the 12 pro max it makes
videos
look like they're shot using a gimbal as
you can see from this video that vadim
took last year
another thing that's coming is an
improved qualcomm x60 modem
and wi-fi 6e this basically means that
battery life will be much more efficient
while using 5g with the new modem
and there will be much less crowding
with the new wi-fi 6e
a small change that's also been
mentioned are stronger magsafe magnets
this isn't a huge deal because maxsafe
is already pretty strong
and works great however there are a few
products like apple's magsafe wallet
that don't hold on very well especially
on the 12 pro max
so with upgraded stronger magnets
accessories like that should be more
secure
which is a nice bonus i'm pretty excited
because i'm planning to use mug safe
wall mounts around the house
and it's nice to know that my phone will
be safe and secure with all of that said
those are the reasons why i will finally
be upgrading my
iphone 10r to the upcoming 13.
and honestly the 120 hertz display
itself would be enough for me to want to
upgrade
but with the other rumored features and
changes like possible under display
touch id
a smaller notch an always on display
better battery life and
vapor chamber cooling it's a no-brainer
for me to upgrade
i love to know what you guys think and
if you're planning to upgrade to
september
so don't forget to let me know check out
those two videos over there
click the button above to subscribe
thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next one